What are your thoughts about taking betanite clay internally for detox help?
So betanite clay is a great binder. So binds other things in your gut.
It's something that's in our clear binder product, our phase five clear binder,
and it's a great binder for things in your gut so that you don't reabsorb them.
Do you take it away from food at least, and away from your other nutrients that you're taking so you're not binding any of those bad?
I'm glad you guys find my sense of humor.
So betanite clay is a great binder so
Oh, that's it. I don't know what I have.
Okay, so if you just search gut on our blog, I have tons of blog posts on gut health.
Some of the things that you think of as far as healing your gut naturally, you have to be careful
when you have cancer because the most common nutritional product to help heal your gut,
going back to that question about the gut back here, is algolutamine because algolutamine helps
epithelial cells reproduce so quickly. Well, you don't want to necessarily do that when you have
any form of cancer. But like deglycerated licorice and a lot of the things that are even those
healing products can be beneficial. We have a product that we have private labels called clear GI.
Now, it does have some algolutamine in it, but it is the reason why a private label that product is
because out of all the gut products that are on the market, it has the least amount of algolutamine.
So I thought that it was going to be fairly safe for our cancer patients.
Because the product label tells you to take a tablespoon a day, and if you only take a teaspoon
a day, you're getting 500 milligrams of glutamine, which is far less than a lot of the gut healing
products out there that you know, someone who have up to four grams of glutamine. So 500 milligrams
or half a gram of glutamine, I thought was acceptable if you're taking it on a shorter basis to
help heal the gut. It also has all these other great things that help with the gut, like slippery
elm and chamomile and okran, cat squad, MSL. And you're already taking courses and I think, but those
are the things that can help heal the gut. But you want to add a probiotic also. And there's been
tons of studies, medical studies out the last couple years that show if you take a probiotic,
whether you take it antibiotic, if you have to take it antibiotic, it definitely reduces your
issues that you can help.